when you imagine the architectural
wonders of the world
what do you see the greatness of the
pyramids of giza
or maybe the amazing aqueducts of
ancient rome
both of these are amazing feats of human
innovation
as an architect i've often wondered why
do we monumentalize
the ancient wonders of civilizations
that collapsed
such a long time ago i've traveled the
world
studying ancient innovation and what
i've found
are indigenous technologies from living
cultures that are still
in use and some of these cultures you
may have
never heard of they live in the most
remote places
on earth facing environmental extremes
like desert drought
and frequent flooding for generations
a couple of years ago i traveled to
northern india to a place
overlooking the plains of bangladesh
where the khasi people live
in a forest that receives more rainfall
than anywhere else
on earth and during the monsoon season
travel between villages
is cut off by these floods which
transform this entire
landscape from a forested canopy into
isolated islands
this hill tribe has evolved living root
bridges that are created by guiding
and growing tree roots that you can
barely wrap
your arms around through a carefully
woven scaffolding
multiple generations of the khasi men
and the women
and the children they'll take care of
these roots as they grow to the other
side of that bank
where they're then planted to make a
structure that will get stronger with
age
this 1500 year-old tradition
of growing living root bridges has
produced 75 of these incredible
structures
and while they take 50 years to grow
in this landscape they actually last for
centuries
all across the globe i've seen cultures
who have been living with floods for
thousands of years by evolving these
ancient technologies that allow them to
work with the water
in the southern wetlands of iraq which
are formed by the confluence of the
tigris and the euphrates rivers
a unique water-based civilization lives
for six thousand years the madonna have
floated villages on
man-made islands that are constructed
from a single
species of reed that grows around them
the kassab
reed is integral to every aspect of life
it is food for water buffalo flower
for humans and building material for
these biodegradable
buoyant islands and their cathedral-like
houses that they construct in as little
as three days and this dried cassava
breed it can be
bundled into columns it can be woven
into floors
or roofs or walls and it can also be
twisted
into a rope that's used to bind these
buildings without the use
of any nails the madan villages
are constructed in the marsh as they
have been
for generations on islands
that stay afloat for over 25
years although global attention is
focused on the pandemic cities are still
sinking
and sea levels are still rising and
high-tech solutions are definitely going
to help us solve
some of these problems but in our rush
towards the future
we tend to forget about the past in
other parts of the world
where rivers are contaminated with
sewerage a city
of 15 million people cleans its
wastewater
with its floodplains on the edges of
calcutta
flanked by a smoking escarpment of the
city's
trash and ribboned by its highways
an indigenous technology of 300 fish
ponds
cleans its water while producing its
food
and through a combination of sunshine
and sewerage and a symbiosis between
algae and bacteria the wastewater is
broken down
fish ponds continue this cleaning of the
water in a process that takes around 30
days
and this innovation it's not just a
model for
chemical and coal power free
purification
since calcutta's core has no formal
treatment
it's the city's only way of cleaning the
water downstream before it enters the
bay of bengal
what i find so unbelievable about this
infrastructure
is that as cities across the world in
asia
and in europe begin to replicate this
exact
system calcutta is now struggling to
save it from being displaced by
development
and then to deal with flooding in a
completely other way
the tufinu tribe has developed the
largest lake city
in africa ganvi meaning
we survived is built of stilted houses
that are organized around a canal system
that you could navigate by dugout canoe
and the royal square
stands amongst 3 000 stilted buildings
that include
a post office a bank a mosque
and even a couple of bars that are all
surrounded by 12
000 individual fish paddocks or
mangrove arches this chemical-free
artificial reef covers almost half of
the lagoon
and feeds 1 million people that are
living around it
what amazes me is that while an
individual
akaja is pretty insignificant when it's
multiplied by 12
000 it creates an indigenous technology
the scale of industrial aquaculture
which is the greatest threat to our
mangrove ecosystems
but this technology it builds more
biodiversity than before
just earlier this year when i was back
home in australia the craziest
thing happened the burned ash from the
bush fires surrounding sydney
rained down on us on bondi beach and
worried about
carbon emissions not viral transmissions
we were already wearing masks
the air was so choked by a plume of
smoke that was so
big that it reached as far away as new
zealand
then in the midst of these wildfires
which were the worst we'd ever seen
on record something unexpected happened
but incredibly amazing the ancestral
lands in australia where indigenous
fire stick farming was practiced were
saved as these fires raged
around them and these ancient forests
they survived because of seasonal
generational burning which is an
aboriginal practice of lighting small
slow and cool fires so though wildfires
are a natural disaster as a consequence
of climate change
they're also man-made and what's amazing
about this is
we have the ancient technology that we
know
can help prevent them and we've used it
for thousands of years
and what i find so fascinating about
these technologies
is how complex they are and how attuned
they are to nature
and then how resilient we could all
become by learning from them
too often when we are faced with a
crisis we build walls
in defense i'm an architect and i've
been trained to seek solutions in
permanence
concrete steel glass these are all
used to build a fortress against nature
but my search for ancient systems and
indigenous technologies
has been different it's been inspired by
an idea that we can seed
creativity in crisis we have
thousands of years of ancient knowledge
that we just need to listen to
and allow it to expand our thinking
about designing
symbiotically with nature and by
listening
we'll only become wiser and ready for
those 21st century challenges
that we know will endanger our people
and our planet and i've seen it
i know that it's possible